there are new warnings that the united
kingdom and the united states withdrawal
from afghanistan could leave the country
as a haven for
terror planning afghan security
officials have warned that the taliban
could renege
on its promises to prevent terror groups
such as al qaeda
operating from within the country uh
well uh
joining us now is afghanistan's national
security
adviser hamdullah mohib thank you very
much indeed for joining us
do you feel let down by the united
kingdom the united states
in pulling out
we uh are dealing with the consequences
of the withdrawal of
u.s troops we we knew this was
happening and this was going to come the
timing of it was a little bit earlier
than uh
previously anticipated um but
you know it's it's down to the afghan
national defense and security forces to
secure and stabilize afghanistan and
that's what we're focused on
you're obviously trying to do that but
uh certainly here
uh in the united kingdom there have been
a lot of reports of the taliban
making quite significant territorial
gains that that is an accurate picture
isn't it
indeed the vacuum created by the
withdrawal of
foreign air power made it very difficult
for us to supply
some of those remote outposts and
districts
by air so it had a cascading effect
but none of the territory the taliban
has taken
is is permanent the afghan people
themselves
are rising against the taliban in their
own villages and districts
and today again this is the 10th
district the afghan national defense and
security forces took
with the help of the people of those
of those districts so much of this
progress that the taliban are
celebrating
is um is very temporary
i much of the work uh done certainly by
uk forces in recent years has been in
supporting and training afghan forces
do you think the government forces are
now stronger than they've ever been
absolutely i think with every year every
passing year we have made progress
the uk had been engaged in helping us
build some of our
uh special operations forces with the
police
and also uh and with with the
with the rest of the and dsf and those
are some of our most
capable forces in our currently engaging
the taliban and offensive operations
and defending some of the difficult the
most difficult terrain
uh possible so we're we're very proud of
our
our forces and um we're thankful for the
partnership that we have had and
as a result the capabilities left in
afghanistan is giving us
a chance for stabilizing our country
what is the state of
negotiations with the taliban we know
there's been one roundtable session
are those negotiations getting anywhere
we haven't yet seen the taliban
negotiate in earnest they're sticking to
a very rigid point and
want to use the negotiating as a
point uh to further their military
agenda and
lobby for their military purposes um
yeah so far there hasn't been um any
uh movement from the taliban uh that
would could be
uh classified as um as genuine
efforts for peace what do you make of
the claims
that some have made that they're
reformed that they're not
uh so repressive towards women or girls
education in other words
the suggestion that uh the afghan people
could could live with
some sort of taliban rule
the districts that the taliban have
taken they have brought back
their brutal ways
of ruling and we are getting
many many messages from all those
districts and there are
complaints throughout about what the
taliban have been
doing in those districts it's um
it's one thing to hear the taliban
make public comments about what has
changed
um the reality is that
they're not very different from what the
taliban were 20 years ago
and the expectation um that that they
will
is i think a little unrealistic
and what do you know if anything of
terrorist groups uh al-qaeda and
obviously
is islamic state has also grown up in
the last 20 years
of coming into taliban controlled areas
and using tissue base is that happening
the taliban have never parted ways with
terrorist groups
there are numerous groups that operate
with
with the taliban alongside the taliban
and have been closely allied with them
from the beginning it's it's it's it
would be impossible for them to separate
them themselves from these groups um
in in this in in the western world um
there is this thinking that perhaps
you know these groups are operating in
silos the taliban
operating in silo and then al qaeda in
daesh
while their management may be
different their management structures
they all rely on those very basic
fundamental fundamentalistic ideologies
that
give them the base of
operations and they cooperate very
closely as as an example
imu the islamic movement of uzbekistan
is an affiliate of the taliban but it
has pledged allegiance to daesh
yet they collaborate very closely so
it's it's a it's a collaboration of
these three groups
in destabilizing afghanistan and
creating a
ground for uh terrorism to flourish
um so we cannot really separate them
and put them in separate categories and
for the taliban to say that they have
severe ties with any any group uh has
been proven wrong by the afghan
government several times
uh by arresting do al-qaeda members and
operating against al-qaeda elements in
taliban controlled areas
finally looking broadly at what's
happened since since 9 11 in the last 20
years
massive loss of life massive military
investment
in afghanistan and yet some people are
saying
country is effectively on the brink of
civil war
what's gone wrong i mean i mean how's
this been able to happen there must have
been a lot of
support from somewhere coming from for
the taliban
forces
well the taliban have had safe heavens
in pakistan
throughout this period they enjoyed
their leaders enjoyed living there
at peace and in in pakistan
they're injured were treated in in
pakistani
hospitals they had military and
emotional support and financial support
from
elements within the pakistani military
establishment
and it continues to be the case so
every year the taliban were defeated in
afghanistan
but they had an opportunity to
recuperate to re-recruit people from
from madrasas in pakistan and bring them
back the next year
and even this year uh we estimate that
uh ten thousand fighters have come uh in
from pakistani madrasas to fight in
afghanistan this fighting season
and their intelligence show that they
they could be as
many as 15 000 more
new recruits coming towards afghanistan
so
um it is it was
possible for the taliban to
reinvent themselves uh relaunch their
attacks
as a result of this this safe heaven
that they
enjoyed uh uh right next door
hundred thank you very much indeed for
joining us